The following is a meditation for the third
fundamental motivation of existential analysis, helping us answer
the question of, am I allowed to be
me?
With an affirmative yes.
The speaker and creator is Graham Nelson Zutter.
Please take a moment to find a seated
position where there's support for your back and
an ability to place your feet flat on
the ground.
You may also find a position sitting in
lotus that feels comfortable.
It may also be helpful to have a
posture where your back is a little more
vertical with your head above your spinal column
with very little strain on your neck.
You may also have a position where you
are resting your head or leaning your head,
just taking a moment to see if there's
an opportunity to find any more comfort.
Perhaps there are pillows or some kinds of
adjustments that you can make to get more
comfortable.
I invite you to close your eyes and
if at any point you find that that's
uncomfortable or doesn't feel safe, that's okay.
If your eyes are open, perhaps you can
find a place to rest your gaze, maybe
at a pattern on the wall or someplace
where there isn't distraction or movement.
I invite you to take a few moments
to get centered in your body, starting with
the feeling of the ground beneath your feet,
the floor beneath your feet, noticing the pressure,
the texture.
If you're wearing footwear or socks or shoes
of some kind or there's a carpet below
you, just noticing the texture the
softness or firmness between you and the floor,
taking a moment to notice this physical support
from under your feet, under your legs.
Just taking a moment to shift your awareness
towards your knees and your hamstrings, starting to
feel the support from under your upper legs,
noticing the shift and pressure between the backs
of your knees towards your hips and glutes
and sitting bones, taking a moment to notice
the firmness and support under your torso, shifting
your awareness to your lower back, starting to
notice the support from behind you as well,
traveling to your middle back and upper back,
shoulders, noticing those places of contact with the
support behind you and taking
a moment to shift your awareness to your
breathing without the need to change how you're
breathing.
When you inhale, perhaps you can feel the
expansion and opening within your chest.
When you exhale, perhaps you can feel the
sensations of rest and relaxation in your chest.
And when you inhale, noticing how you're bringing
nourishment in the form of oxygen into your
body, replenishing what your cells need, what they
thrive on.
And as you exhale, releasing the carbon dioxide
that your body no longer needs.
Maybe noticing where your skin is exposed to
the air, sticking in the experience of being
in contact with the air, the very same
air that holds this oxygen that you're inhaling
and the carbon dioxide that you're releasing.
Perhaps you notice the temperature of the air
on your skin, inviting you to
also notice that you're wearing clothing, just noting
those areas of your skin covered by clothes.
Perhaps there's a light pressure from your clothes.
Maybe there's a shift in temperature.
Perhaps you can even feel the texture of
the fabric.
Noticing that both your skin and
your
outside world.
Taking a moment to realize there's nothing for
you to do.
This boundary that your skin and clothing provides
is just there.
Maybe noticing that you've continued to breathe, even
without the need to focus on your breath.
If you forget to breathe, that's okay.
Your body will continue to breathe for you.
Noticing the support from behind and below.
They too do not require any kind of
doing.
They're just there.
Just taking a moment to realize that this
protection, this openness and support are just here.
Maybe also taking a moment to notice what
it's like to calm, to shift your focus
towards your experience of the now at this
moment and at this time.
Connecting with yourself and giving yourself the opportunity
to just slow down, to spend some time
with you, to be close with yourself, and
to take the time to just notice how
you are in this moment.
In our previous session, we noticed that we
have a relationship to the earth as it
supports us and as it does in this
moment as well.
We also took some time to notice this
vitality of the breath and its connection to
our plant friends.
Noticing how we're in relationship with trees and
that when the sun shines, that sunlight helps
the trees take the carbon dioxide that we
exhale and share with them and transform that
carbon dioxide into oxygen, the very same oxygen
that we breathe.
Just taking a moment to notice this relationship
between your body and the nourishment that you
receive in the form of breath and that
reciprocity that we have with all the trees
in the world.
Next, I'm going to invite you to imagine
a bit of an adventure, an adventure we
can go on together.
I invite you to imagine that you're strolling
and you come upon a park or a
meadow.
This may be a park or a meadow
that you're familiar with.
It may be an entirely new place.
Taking a moment to notice what it's like
to cross this threshold from the busy world
of humans into the world where there's a
little more room for nature, a little more
space for life.
Giving yourself permission to cross this threshold and
enter into this more natural space.
Just see where you feel like going perhaps
you're drawn this way or that.
Giving yourself permission to make whatever choice feels
right for you and as you continue to
stroll through this open space, you notice a
tree.
You feel drawn to this tree so you
gently make your way towards it.
This may be a tree that you've met
before.
It may be an entirely new tree.
Taking a moment here to notice the shape
of this tree.
Do you notice if it's more tall than
wide or more wide than tall?
It's noticing the energy of this tree and
how it takes space.
How comfortable it seems where it is.
Noticing how its pace seems to be at
a really gentle, patient time scale.
As you take in the tree you notice
off to the side that there's a picnic
table.
It seems as if something has been left
on this picnic table.
Following your curiosity, making your way over to
the picnic table, noticing that there seems to
be some objects on this table.
There is a box of colored crayons with
so many choices of colors.
There's a little stack of nice art paper.
There's a nice bag that's perfect in size
to carry these supplies around.
And there's a little note left on top
of the paper near the crayons.
And the note just says, enjoy.
Noticing that you've made space to be in
this environment.
Taking a moment for yourself to just be
with nature.
The choice presents itself that you too might
take a moment to enjoy yourself even more.
And you decide to sit down on the
bench seating of this picnic table.
Noticing that the table and the seating is
facing the tree that you are just admiring.
And it dawns on you that you could
draw this tree.
And as you begin to look at this
tree, you feel inspired to choose crayons from
this box of crayons.
Noticing the different colors of the tree.
There may have been times in the past
where coloring felt difficult or like you had
to get it right.
And this is not one of these moments.
Today, drawing is easy.
And this practice is just for you in
this moment.
As you notice different parts of the tree,
you're able to draw these shapes, textures, and
colors with ease on the paper.
You notice the shape of the tree, how
tall and how wide it is.
Noticing if this tree has leaves or needles.
Noticing the shape and the color of the
canopy of this tree.
Drawing all of that in with ease of
the colors that feel right.
Making your way to the branches and the
bows of the tree.
All the way to the trunk of the
tree.
Noticing the color of the bark.
Whether it is smooth or bumpy.
Maybe it has ridges.
Noticing that different parts of the bark may
have different colors.
And you draw whatever you want to from
this tree as you notice its shapes and
colors and movement.
There's no right or wrong way.
As you use these colored crayons, you notice
to feel this sense of satisfaction.
That your perception, your admiration for this tree
is being captured in this moment.
In your rendition, you're noticing your inspiration
of this great tree.
If you feel like it, you can also
use one piece of paper or multiple pieces
of paper.
Taking your time to focus wherever your attention
goes.
There's no right or wrong here.
Whatever you feel drawn towards, you can draw
on the paper.
And as your drawing or drawings take shape,
you notice how nice they are.
Almost like you're respecting this tree.
You're giving a rendition that captures some essence
of how you feel towards this tree.
The impact that it has on you to
be in its presence.
Be noticing how nice it is to spend
this time allowing yourself to be creative and
really appreciating how beautiful this tree is in
this setting.
Feeling good that there are spaces like this.
It's important to have these spaces where you
can be creative and connect with nature.
And as you draw and collect all of
your impressions, at some point when you're ready,
it dawns on you that a really close
friend of yours is going to be at
a cafe not long or far from here.
And having had so much fun expressing yourself
and being creative, you feel pretty satiated and
decide, yeah, it'd be really nice to see
this close friend of mine.
You collect your crayons back in a crayon
box and assemble your beautiful drawings of this
tree.
And you take the paper drawings and crayons
and put them in this satchel, this bag
that they fit in perfectly.
And as you collect them, you start to
make your way towards the entrance of this
meadow or park.
And before you leave, just taking a moment
to look over your shoulder, feeling this sense
of enjoyment with this tree and this green
space.
Almost imagining like the tree is saying goodbye
to you.
Maybe offering you a see you later and
feeling the sense of warmth from this connection
you've had with the tree.
Making your way out of the park, strolling
towards this park, this cafe.
As you arrive, you notice your friend.
And your friend already knows what drink you
like.
Whether you're a coffee or tea person, they've
chosen the drink that you like, that you've
told them that you enjoy in the past.
And it's such a nice treat to sit
down with them, seeing that they remembered what
you like.
You notice the warmth of being close to
someone that cares for you, that you care
for.
Maybe you get a nice hug or a
little bisou, cheek to cheek.
You sit down and you start to catch
up.
Noticing how nice it is to spend this
time with this friend.
Maybe noticing their gestures, how they move, the
tone of their voice, their sense of excitement
and interest, and how their energy affects you.
And your friend asks you, what have you
been up to today?
How has your day off been?
And it dawns on you that you had
just recently spent some time in a clean
space.
Did you share this experience with your friend?
And part of telling your story includes, oh
yeah, the darndest thing happened.
I was walking in the park, in this
meadow area, and I noticed this beautiful tree
that really captured my attention.
And as I walked closer to the tree,
I noticed there was a picnic bench with
crayons and art paper, and this sack that
I'm carrying right now.
And your friend looks at you in amazement
and pleasure, and you share with them that
you decided to take the time to enjoy
the crayons, enjoy the art paper, and just
having a moment of expression.
No one was there to evaluate your work
or tell you what to do or not
do, and you found yourself in this moment
of easy inspiration and connection with your creativity,
noticing what it felt like to really appreciate
and be inspired by the shape of this
tree.
And your friend asks you, would it be
possible to see your drawings?
And in this moment, you notice the sense
of joy and courage, and with excitement, you
open up your bag and bring out your
beautiful drawings, showing them to your friend.
And as your friend takes in the art
that you've created, you hear their comments on
how beautiful the shapes are, how much they
appreciate your choice of color, how vibrant these
colors are.
Your friend zooms in on little details that
you've captured, or the abstract sense of movement
of the tree that you've captured.
You notice just how much care you've put
in and how much joy it looks like
you had while creating these drawings.
Your friend says to you, wow, it really
feels like you captured the personality of this
tree.
I'm so glad you had this opportunity.
Thank you so much for sharing with me.
What a lovely surprise.
A lovely surprise that you got to find
the tree.
A lovely surprise that these tools of art
were left for you to enjoy.
And what a lovely surprise for your friend
to be able to enjoy your creativity.
There's a real sense of appreciation from your
friend.
And in a moment of inspiration, you ask
them if they would like one of your
drawings.
And they reply, yes, I would love one
of your drawings.
I know just where to put it.
And they describe the place in their home
or their office where they'd really like to
be able to see your drawing and enjoy
it.
They describe how other people in their home
and their workspace will also have the benefit
of enjoying this portrait of this beautiful tree
that you found.
And you've done such justice to this tree.
You've had so much freedom in your expression
that you feel super comfortable about this idea
of other people appreciating your art.
Maybe you're not an artist, and yet you're
so capable of creativity and connection.
And you notice the sense of pride, maybe
even a sense of justice that is good
and right to spend this time being expressive,
connecting with nature, being creative, noticing just how
good it feels to share your discovery of
this beautiful tree with your friend.
And you and your friend continue to have
your lovely catch-up conversation, sipping your drinks.
And after you both have had lots of
chances to share about your lives, things that
are happening, updates on relationships, you notice that
it's a natural time to say goodbye, you
and your friend making plans for a future
hangout.
And you start to make your way home,
waving goodbye to your friend, noticing the sensation
in your body of what connection feels like.
And also what it's like to be really
vulnerable with someone and have that vulnerability accepted
with such enthusiasm and interest.
What a good experience.
You feel pretty satisfied that it's right for
you to take the time to really rest
and relax in a park, to give yourself
this gift, this opportunity to enjoy nature and
discover such a beautiful tree and how generous
and kind it was for this unknown stranger
to leave these art supplies for you.
What a lucky, wonderful moment.
And what a surprise it was for you
to share your creativity with your friend.
What a good day, just enjoying your stroll
on the way home.
And as you get into this rhythm of
your stroll, I invite you to start to
return to the shared space, the space where
your physical body is, the space where this
physical support is underneath you and taking your
time.
If your eyes are closed, gently opening them
and coming back into this room together and
giving yourself just another moment to appreciate this
investment of time connecting with your creativity and
your intuition.
You'll be noticing what it would be like
if you gave yourself more of this time,
this growing awareness that you deserve to spend
more time with nature and that nature would
like to spend more time with you.
And that this connection between you and nature
is something that also improves other people.
Sharing our experiences in nature with those we
care for brings connection and joy to them
as well and may inspire them to also
take this time to connect and be in
nature.